Hello world,
it's Saroj and who's ready to watch me build an AI startup.
In this video I'm going to show you how to build an AI startup from start to
finish.
What I mean is we're going to build a simple prototype and I have it right here
for you.
It's called Smart Med scan.
Let me show you a quick demo.
It's running locally on my machine as you see behind me,
I've called it smart med scan.
Clearly I need to design it a little better,
but uh,
it's a prototype.
And what I'm going to show you is how this works first and then the entire
pipeline of how we would ideate,
how we would design a business plan,
how we would get our first clients,
and then how we would grow our startup.
Okay.
Over time.
So it hopefully this whole video shows gives you an overview of how I would do
this.
I'm going to show you,
give you all of my secrets of how I would do this.
I'm going to be totally transparent and open with you.
All right?
So check this out.
So the first step for user is to sign up for Smart Med scan.
And who is this for?
This is a tool for doctors to be able to classify images or medical images.
So you know,
x ray scans for their lungs.
Doctors have all sorts of images that they spend many years learning how to
classify with their brain.
But um,
there's a,
there's a shortage of doctors out there.
Um,
it's expensive and a lot of times there's a lot of miss misdiagnoses out there,
right?
So,
which is bad for patients in terms of their health and it's bad for doctors in
terms of liabilities.
So we want to avoid that.
And the way to do that is to use these deep learning and machine learning
technologies to do that for us and to help doctors to make their jobs easier.
It's make patients lives better.
Okay.
So my email,
let's see,
I've got all my basic details here.
Password,
um,
another password and I'll submit.
Okay.
So now that I've signed in,
I'm going to pay with card.
Okay.
So I'm a doctor,
I have an image.
I want it,
I want to classify it.
So I'm gonna pay with my card.
I'm gonna say,
you know this my email,
here's my test card number,
or whatever it is,
it's fake.
And then here's my CVC CVC.
I'm going to pay 10 bucks for a single classification.
I'll go ahead and pay the charge goes through.
Okay.
And it says,
great job.
Thanks for paying 10 bucks.
Go ahead and upload your file.
This now shows up and I'm going to say,
uh,
yeah.
Let's see.
I'll say this one.
Here's my medical image.
Submit it.
It's running inference right now in the cloud or on my machine is running in
France.
This is machine learning happening right now.
It's classifying it.
Okay?
Okay,
so now I've uploaded it.
It's classified it,
and we can see the classification results right underneath,
right here.
It is very likely that this is an example of pneumonia.
This is something that people go to school for years to do,
and we just figured out how to automate that,
which is amazing.
It's going to help doctors and help patients.
It's going to make life better.
And so here's an example,
right?
And I have different options,
different pricings,
a thousand USD,
you know,
even more for enterprise hospitals,
bigger,
bigger medical institution so you can see how this could work.
So I'm going to show you how I did this,
how I built this,
and how I would plan to grow this.
Okay?
So it's a 10 step process.
I'm going to list some of my problems.
I'm going to pick one that I feel most passionate about.
I'm going to do some market research for competing products.
I'm going to buy a domain,
create a landing page,
get some customers,
uh,
create a business plan,
designed the actual pipeline for the real APP.
When I build it,
build the APP and then deploy it.
And you'll see all of those steps.
All right?
So,
so the first step is going to be too fine.
A problem that I actually care about.
And uh,
what we can do is we can frame it like this or there are problems that you care
about,
their passions you have and their strengths that you have,
right?
So one example would be me,
So my passion would be to educate people.
It's also,
it happens to be my strength and there happens to be a problem where not enough
people understand how this AI technology works.
So the star then would be to educate people about Ai.
So that is,
that would be my real life startup,
which it is.
And I do make money from that.
So this is a startup.
It's,
it's more,
it's,
it's grown past startup stage at this point.
It's like mid size.
Anyway,
so,
so that's a very kind of basic way to think about,
you know,
write down what your strengths are,
write down what your passions are,
write down what the problems you care about are,
and then look for the intersection of those three.
And in fact,
the Japanese have codified this more than a hundred years ago with the concept
of Icky guy.
It literally means a reason for being.
And this,
this chart here shows you what all of that entails,
what you love,
what you're good at,
what you can be paid for,
and what the world needs.
And that the intersection of all of those four things is your eeky guy.
And you want to find that,
right?
So one way to do that is to write down what I,
what I said,
but also look at the industries that are available,
right?
So artificial intelligence is going to transform every industry,
It's not just hype,
it's reality.
And this is going to continue to happen.
Ai Is a new electricity as Professor Ang says.
And so what you can do is you can look at these industries and you can pick and
choose one that you would one.
So for me,
I'm going to pick and choose three.
My three passions are healthcare,
education,
and scientific research.
So a good thought exercise would be to say,
you know,
hey,
this problem sucks.
How many people have had had this problem?
How many other ways are there to solve it?
What,
what would it cost to offer a solution?
And how does the cost compared to the pain of the problem?
And so for me,
I'm going to pick one problem in particular of my three passions.
Healthcare,
right?
And so it's going to be in healthcare.
And specifically I know that image classification technology is really good then
and so then it happens.
So what happens is we have to pick one of those subfields of healthcare.
I'm going to say radiology specifically for lungs.
That's going to be the one that I'm,
I'm most passionate about because in this example I have somebody who I know who
has been affected by it.
And here's a story,
right?
So,
so that's,
that's how to think about it.
But if you cannot think of a problem,
no matter what you're doing,
do this,
just leave wherever you are for a month.
It just go to a totally different culture and you've got to increase your
training data,
right?
So find,
find new training data,
find new cultures,
new values,
new languages,
new people,
new perspectives.
And I promise you,
you will find a problem that you are passionate about.
You will find your [inaudible] guy.
You need to get out of your bubble and go forth into strange territory that
scares you,
right?
I lived in Amsterdam for a year.
I've lived all over the world at this point,
Tokyo,
Singapore,
everywhere.
So,
and it definitely helps you find that passion.
So definitely do that.
Okay,
that's step one.
We did that.
Now I have the problem healthcare for doctors and we're going to automate
healthcare via a classifier.
Now the next step is to do some market research.
What are the competing products here?
By the way,
AI can do literally so much.
This is just a subset of what AI can do.
It can do anything with natural language processing.
It could generate text,
it could classify texts,
it could summarize text.
Uh,
you can use computer vision to see things in classify things.
You can generate new types of images for fashion lines and you can retrieve
information in a very intelligent way.
You know,
there's so much information out there.
How do you compress it and how do you present to a customer or user the most
useful information that is,
uh,
an AI problem?
How do you filter what they want and what they don't want?
How do you predict the future in finance,
in asset prediction,
in portfolio optimization?
How do you make the best decisions when you have a giant company at giant
organization that's decision analytics,
how you improve the supply chain process.
How do you classify these plants that need to be classified?
If you're,
if you're a farmer and you're trying to get rid of weeds and increase your
supplies,
do you see what I'm saying?
Ai applies to literally every industry,
the basic human senses of vision,
of speech,
of,
of recognizing texts and understanding language,
machine translation.
All of this can be automated and we can create services to do this for us.
So then we can focus on creative pursuits were more meaningful lives,
et cetera.
That's a little metta.
You see what I'm saying?
So if we look at the uh,
field of,
of Ai in healthcare,
we know that this is something we can do,
right?
Input,
output,
simple input,
pattern recognition,
right?
We have the input,
it's going to be a medical image.
We have our classifier that we're going to build and it's going to output what
the disease is.
Very simple.
Pattern recognition,
supervised learning,
find a labeled dataset.
Easy stuff.
We can do that.
Now,
if we look at the competitor landscape for this,
and I found this image,
you know,
out there there's general imaging and these people try to do everything that,
they're classifying breast cancer,
they're classifying,
you know,
um,
all sorts of the whole body.
Then there's like specific niches here.
So we're going to pick this niche,
which is a lung imaging,
right?
So if we look at this,
these lung imaging startups,
I go to Mbo,
I'll check it out.
What does it look like?
Okay.
They have this trial situation.
Do they have a freemium model?
No.
They look kind of a pulmonary AI.
Okay.
So they're doing that fully automated.
I don't know.
I think it can be done better that there's sites kind of,
you know,
old school and you could just make it hipper and look,
there's so many different,
uh,
medical facilities out there and they're probably the only targeting the US or
the UK or the EU.
We've got the world to upgrade,
right?
So we can target those markets that they're not going to target.
We're going to target the entire world will figure out the regulations when we
get there.
That's the startup mentality.
That's how Uber did it.
That's how we're going to do it.
And the lung imaging landscape looks pretty disruptable.
It's not specialized enough.
They're trying to do everything we're going to,
we're going to do is we're going to laser focus on one type of medical image and
that that are,
those are the lungs,
right?
Lung images.
We're going to focus on those.
We're going to do that really,
really well.
We're going to do that better than anybody else because we have the data and the
technology to do that freely available.
And when we do that and we build a customer base,
then we're going to grow and then we're going to start applying it to all sorts
of medical images.
And that's,
that's how that looks.
All right,
so we have done our market research and assume that I looked through all of
these are right.
So this third step is to buy a domain and you know,
go to go daddy,
whatever you want.
I'm not endorsing Godaddy,
just like pick a domain by it and that's it.
Right?
So when we go to go daddy,
we can type in smart med scan and see if there's exist.
Any other great,
it's available.
Smart Med scan is available.
Good.
We'll go ahead and buy it.
I'm not going to do that right now.
So we assumed we bought it.
Now the next step is create a landing page.
And to do that we need a logo,
right?
We need a logo.
Now I use this AI tool to generate a logo for me.
It's pretty amazing.
It's called brandmark.
Okay.
And when it does is it uses AI to create a logo for you?
It generates it.
It's a,
it's a generative network that they're using in the back background here.
So I'll say it's called Smart Med scan.
We bought the go daddy domain or whatever domain you buy from and it's going to
be related to hospitals and they're using NLP here to relate images via some
semantic similarity index here,
hospital deep learning.
These are my keywords and it's going to then deep learning AI.
So you already knew Ai.
And I'll say,
here's the color scheme that we want and it's going to generate a logo for us.
We don't have to do that ourselves.
And we're going to use this logo and this color scheme to create a landing page,
right?
So check out all these beautiful logo,
smart,
smart med scan right here,
smart med scans.
So we would just pick one and we would say,
okay,
so here it is.
Smart Med scan,
deep learning for hospitals.
Look,
it's got the guy with the shirt,
man,
I love this,
I love this site.
Um,
look,
it's got the guy looking at it as well.
Let's not get too,
let's not get too enamored by this right now anyway.
It's amazing.
It's so pay them,
definitely pay them and stuff like I did guys like,
but also like if you don't have money you can just kind of like screenshot it as
well.
You know,
they,
they must've known that's possible.
So whatever,
you know,
if you support them,
pay them.
But like if you're going to do that,
just do that as well.
Whatever it takes,
you know?
So anyway,
so that's to create a logo and now we're going to create a landing page.
Okay?
So the whole idea of a landing page is that we want to know if we're going to
actually have customers before we build this thing.
We don't want to waste our time.
I did that before with the robotic startup.
I don't want it.
We don't want to waste our time again.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to create a landing page that demos this
idea with the logo,
and it's going to have an email.
It's kind of a single field to enter your email if you want to learn more.
And what we're going to do is we're going to have a one liner describe what the
product is.
We're going to put the price,
and then we're going to say,
here it is.
If you're interested,
sign up.
And what we're gonna do is we're gonna find a bunch of medical facilities near
us.
We're going to ping them and say,
Hey,
are you interested in,
hopefully we get some people to sign up.
And if we do,
that is called market validation.
That's how we know that people actually want our product.
And the easiest way to do this is to use MailChimp,
which is a tool that I generally use.
And so we can say mail chimp landing page.
And what mail chip allows you to do is this,
it's got this free landing page builder.
You can try it out and I'll say it's called test,
select the list,
whatever,
you know,
whatever.
And we'll begin that.
And Alex,
I'll pick one of these.
Let's just pick this one,
right?
So see here it is email address.
When they sign up,
it goes into your MailChimp account and that's how you collect emails.
And so we can,
you know,
change all of this to like med scan,
whatever,
you know,
we can change the tax,
add all this stuff and we'll just that this is easy stuff,
but you got the point.
And once we have it,
we'll do save and close,
save and close.
And then we'll say,
um,
add a URL and it's going to generate a URL for us.
Save.
Okay.
And then we'll say add page title,
unentitled whatever,
publish.
Yeah.
And now here's our landing page right here.
Okay.
Right?
So here's our landing page.
Obviously we need to change it,
but you get the point,
you can quickly make a landing page and then we'll link our go daddy domain to
this,
right?
So on the backend we just changed the name servers,
uh,
to,
to this one or you know,
or you saw that option that it had to use your own,
which you could do.
But anyway,
that's the point.
And so then what we would do is,
right,
so we create our Lenny,
we create our,
our landing page.
And now step five is to share that landing page.
So let's share that landing page so we can,
you know,
Sharon,
our social networks,
you know,
on Facebook,
whatever it is,
like,
hey,
sign up for this.
Hey,
sign up.
You know,
make it a better pitch.
But like,
Hey,
I,
you know,
if you're interested,
I have a startup for doctors.
Sign up here,
sign up here,
coming soon,
right?
Whatever it is,
and then,
you know,
add the link.
And then the other thing we can do is we can go to maps and then we can say
inside of Google maps,
what are the places that are near me?
And we can search and then we can find what those places are and we'll just see.
We'll email them or know,
call them wherever.
We'll send them this link with a nice pitch,
right?
So that's the fifth step.
And once we have a list,
the next step for us is to create a business plan.
Now there are,
so there's so much advice that exists out there on how to create a business
plan,
write a one page summary,
define your target market.
And the reason we want to do this is just to kind of pan out what the idea would
look like in our heads for ourselves.
It's for ourselves more than anyone else.
So my idea is to get,
you know,
25 signups for the landing page,
create the APP,
and then give those signups the APP,
convert some of those signups to actual paid clients.
Collect some feedback,
like did these doctors like it?
What didn't they like about it?
You know,
they're like,
oh,
fix this,
add this,
I'll do that.
I'll improve the APP with the data,
data driven.
Then I'll collect a hundred more paid clients,
which I arbitrarily picked as a number.
I'll repeat steps four through six,
right?
Collecting feedback and growing the APP until I can't do it anymore myself and I
have to hire people,
then I'll make two of the most unnecessary hires,
a full stack engineer who can do both Mlai web and mobile,
eventually development and a salesman to go out or woman to find people and to
get them to,
you know,
sign up for our service.
And then eventually,
um,
I might,
I may or may not raise the first round and um,
then higher,
larger team,
the step 12 and 13 are just a joke.
And then the exit strategy will be to be bought out by one of these big tech
companies or buy them out.
We'll see.
You know,
it depends on how ambitious we want to be and this is called the lean startup
mentality.
I would highly recommend checking out this book.
Uh,
it's a great book by Eric Reese and it,
it talks about how to do this basically,
you know,
Tldr of the entire book is don't just try to raise money,
just build as much as you can without making,
you know,
while being frugal,
while being frugal.
And,
and that is how you build a real business.
Okay.
So now on to step seven,
step seven is going to be to design a pipeline.
So what we know we need is first of all,
we need there to be a database of users.
So authentication,
functionality,
right?
That's very basic.
Just sign up,
log in,
right?
That we know we need that and we also need a database to store those users.
So we're going to use sequel.
Sql is the goto default database that,
you know,
we use these days and obviously there are others,
but for,
uh,
you know,
we're trying to build a prototype as fast as possible.
Rapid experimentation.
It's one of our values at school of AI just rapidly experiment until we get to
whatever solution we need.
Try fail,
try,
fail,
try fail.
So,
um,
right.
So we want to use a SQL database for our user authentication,
for our database to store those users and then we can need a way for them to be
able to pay us and the way to pay people,
and I'm biased because I use it myself and I have used it is stripe.
I love stripe.
I love you guys.
I love the design of everything and um,
stripe rules.
So Stripe is the way to collect payments,
right?
So,
so once a user signs up,
they'll need to be able to pay,
we'll need to be able to collect their card information easily stored in a
secured way.
And then once they do that,
we want to allow them to upload their images.
So flask,
we'll natively allow us to do that.
Speaking of Flask Flask is a web development framework for python.
And the reason that I chose flasks cause because I'm most familiar with it,
however,
Django works just as well,
pyramid air pair.
And there are a million other ones,
but flasks seems to have a lot of good documentation,
a lot of good repositories on Github,
which makes me more inclined to use it.
And lastly,
once they've uploaded their file,
they've logged in,
they paid what is the last thing we want them to do?
We want them to,
uh,
you to perform inference using our AI model,
which will then classify,
which will diagnose,
uh,
the medical image.
And we use carrots for that.
Okay,
so let's see.
The naive way to do this would be to just build it from scratch,
but we are not naive are we?
We recognize how beautiful get hub is.
Now I'm going to take a second here to educate you on how powerful to get hubs
search is,
right?
So we have to be really good with search and get hub,
the repository for code on the Internet.
We know we want,
uh,
we know we want a flask APP,
so we know that.
We also know that we want it to have payments and probably stripe integrated.
So let's just search flask stripe on all of get hub.
And we've got some great
look at this.
We've got some great repositories that already exist.
And guess what these people did.
They integrated payments,
user authentication and a database for us.
This is kind of boiler plate has nothing to do with Ai.
It's just a web app.
And this,
they did it for us.
So what we can do is we can build off of their APP.
And so you know,
I tried several of these and one that I've found worked pretty well was called
Flask Sas,
which a this guy bill tier and what we can build off of his work.
So we're going to go ahead and clone,
download this straight from get hub.
Okay.
And uh,
we'll get into that in a second.
Okay.
So,
and then we want to add upload functionality,
right?
Who,
who does,
who has upload functionality,
Flask Image uploader.
Oh,
he's got a running demo right there and he's got the code right here.
Uh,
that's simple.
See We,
you have to be able to use get hub for the,
for what it is.
It is an incredibly,
an incredibly useful tool to allow you to rapidly prototype by putting together
components that already exist to create something entirely new.
That's the whole point,
right?
So really you gotta be,
you gotta be very smart about using good hub in looking at those keywords and
searching it because it is the Google for code,
right?
So it's like whatever you want,
you know,
medical flask,
medical pro,
I don't know if somebody is going to show up,
probably a flask python web app running on Apache.
How much could we learn from that?
Right.
There's so much.
It's so rich with ideas,
right?
So definitely look at,
look into search and get hub and learning how to,
you know,
have a laser focus on what is useful out of get hub.
Okay.
And so the idea is like,
okay,
so once they've authenticated,
we got their payment functionality.
What we can do is we can build off of this flask Sass App and that upload
functionality,
add our carrots,
you know,
snippet of code.
And then have a call back where if upload,
you know,
if the user has signed in and they've already paid,
then run in France if and only if then run in France and then display the result
as html.
You see what I'm saying?
So that's the pipeline that we want for the prototype.
Now we're going to perform transfer learning.
So the whole idea behind transfer learning is to not have us have to waste a lot
of our time training our model on,
uh,
an extremely large dataset.
It's not going to,
it's also not going to require a lot of computational power.
So the,
the way to do that as the first decide what technique we're going to use for
medical imaging classification.
And we know that convolutional networks,
a type of ml model tend to do really well.
Now I'm not gonna explain how they work.
I have a great video on that called convolutional neural network.
Just search youtube Suraj it'd be the first link.
Watch that come back if you don't know how they work to this video.
Pause,
open new tab,
watch come back,
right?
So dependencies,
life full of dependencies.
Back to this convolutional networks,
they do really well at image classification,
hot dog,
not hot dog cancer,
not cancer,
right?
Diabetes,
not diabetes.
And so it's a very simple process.
We train the model with labeled data,
then we applied to unlabeled data and it will make a prediction.
That's it,
right?
So now we're going to write our web app web APP,
and then we're going to deploy step nine,
right?
Our web APP and then deploy.
So before we do that,
check this out.
So what I did was I took some time to write out this transfer learning code.
And what this code does is
it will use care Ross,
the deep learning library to build off an existing model.
So let me go back for a second and show you something that I forgot to show you.
And so there exists a lot of different types of pretrained classification models
that Google and other institutions have built.
And what we can do is we can leverage those pretrained models.
And I'm doing this because it represents all the layers of what it's learned
before,
right?
So inception for example,
it's like 50 layers of everything.
It's learned from dogs to planes to everything.
And what we do is we cut off the final layer.
By cutoff,
I mean we were moved that final matrix,
um,
that the,
the final set of matrices that store all of its learnings,
we remove it and then we take the rest of this,
we take the head off the Hydra and then we,
we retrain this existing model on our medical imaging Dataset.
And the reason we do that rather than do it from scratch is it improves accuracy
if we leverage all the general features that it's learned from things as random
as umbrellas and trains and cars,
all of that will improve the accuracy of our specific niche,
which,
which is surprisingly,
it does,
which is medical imaging.
And so that's the idea behind transfer learning.
Train a model on a giant Dataset and then we'll just exist as a component,
as a building block to further AI models that we build that are more
specialized.
The technical term it our downstream tasks.
Okay.
So we're going to pick one of these models and we're going to do it.
And so what I did was I built the code to,
to to show you what this looks like.
Well,
first import our dependencies,
right?
This is running tensorflow and care os,
and then this is the line that's very important.
Image net.
Here's the weight.
It's going to load an existing convolutional network that was trained by Google
in a single line of code,
okay?
And then we'll add some more layers to improve accuracy,
Then what we do is we say,
okay,
here's our model.
Here are the inputs,
here are the predictions.
Now here's the line where I'm talking about the cutting off part,
right?
So if it's lower than 20 layers,
it's not trainable.
If it's greater than 20 layers,
it's trainable.
So we're only making the last parts retrainable.
Then what we do is we import our data from Kaggle,
right?
So I have many videos on how this works.
Search,
Kaggle,
Suraj and so we'll,
we'll authenticate with Kaggle.
We'll pull that data set from Kaggle
and took,
let me show you what this looks like.
Our dataset,
here's our data set of Kaggle images,
5,863 images,
you know,
pneumonia,
viral pneumonia,
all of those diseases.
We can pull it directly from Kaggle.
Okay,
so that's our dataset.
It's got those.
These are the three labels.
And then the images are the other column.
It's right.
So it's a labeled dataset and we can pull this directly from Kaggle.
And then once we've downloaded it into our colab research environment,
we can take that data,
we can say,
here's the data,
train it on that data,
compile it,
it's going to train.
And then we download the weights.
And to do that,
what we do is we put it in our Google drive and then we download it to our local
machine and then we apply and then we point to it,
the dot h five file are all of the learnings that it's learned on the web.
It will then connect to that and I'll show you how to do that locally.
So that's transfer learning.
Now we're on to step nine.
We're,
we're almost done.
We've got to write our web APP,
so let's write our web apps.
Starting with that boiler plate that we just downloaded right here.
It's called flask SAS master.
Okay,
so it's called flask SAS master one.
Dot.
Sip.
So I'm going to copy that.
I'm going to go here.
I'm going to,
then,
let's see.
Let's make this bigger.
Let's do this.
I love terminal.
Here we go.
CD,
intuit,
boom,
we're there.
Okay,
sublime.
Open it up.
Here's our file.
Now,
where were we?
What was the name of that file?
It's called flasks.
Sas.
And what are the instructions to run it?
Set up,
make,
install and make dev great.
We can do that.
Okay,
great.
That worked.
Create the database.
Python three
great.
Sql database has been created and now we run the application.
That's right.
Python three.
Here we go.
Hey Ay ay.
Okay,
so we just built it.
There it is.
It's there.
We did it.
Good job.
High Five.
Okay,
so it's a,
it's a,
it's bare bones.
It's got nothing,
but it's got a Nav bar.
It's got sign up functionality there and now we can just modify it.
Look how easy that was,
right?
So I'm going to sign up and say whatever,
whatever,
and then whatever@whatever.com and then whatever,
whatever.
Okay,
great.
Check your email to confirm.
Great.
So it's got that.
It's right.
So we did that.
Now we've,
we've immediately,
we have our authentication,
our database running.
This would have taken us forever and we have done it so fast.
Awesome.
So let's,
let's keep going here.
Let's look at what this app has in your,
how,
how has this APP structured.
We need to understand it.
So let's look at in the con config file.
So in the config file,
um,
this person added the credentials for the database to sequel lite database.
Um,
they've got the mail server or great stuff like that.
What we want to do is we want to add an upload folder,
right?
So these are these,
these are global keywords.
So one thing we want to do is we want to add an upload folder that's going to
store whatever images that doctors or whoever uploads in,
since it's on my local machine to start,
I'm just going to name it whatever my local
directory is called.
Okay.
That's it.
That's my upload folder.
And that's all right.
So anyway,
let's see what else I've got here.
And so let's look in the index file.
The index file.
Okay,
so if we go to index,
here's the index,
right?
That that home page,
if the current users authenticated,
then show hi username.
Okay,
makes sense.
And it says it's extending from layout dot.
Html.
Okay,
so what's in layout?
That's where the good stuff is.
Okay,
then now we've got some style sheets.
Now we got to brush up on our a html and javascript.
Okay?
Okay.
So what we can do is we can add our logo here,
right?
So remember that brand Mark Logo,
assume that you screenshotted it,
then you uploaded it to injure,
right?
Then what you can do is you can say,
let me add that right.
Let's say here
and then let's see what it looks like.
Boom,
there's our logo,
there's our low go.
And so what we can do now is we can change the rest of the,
um,
we can change the rest of the attributes and CSS to make it look more like what
we would want it to look like.
So we'll say for this entire container,
we want the background.
Uh,
it's,
we're going to say it's going to be a
okay
background color,
just like that.
Okay.
Which is the color that brand mark gave us.
And then we go back here.
The whole thing is that color,
the whole thing became that color.
Good.
It's beautiful.
Now we got a center it,
I mean,
you know what it is.
We've got a center of this thing now.
Center Center.
Center
closing.
Good.
Good,
good,
good.
All right,
so we did that.
Now what are we going to do?
So now we want to add our pricing.
So what we can do is we can go to stripe and first you got to create an account
at stripe,
right?
So I have an account and once we're in our stripe account,
we can go to the developers tab,
we can find our API keys.
And so we have to Api keys.
We have a publishable and a secret key always.
I'm going to change this by the time the video is there.
So it's all good.
So Stripe has several very easy code snippets that we can just paste in that
will immediately take someone's car details and then allow us to authenticate
their,
their details,
make a charge,
and it's going to show up in our stripe balance.
So we don't have to worry about that.
Obviously they take a cut,
that's their business model,
but it's uh,
it's,
it's working well.
So what we can do is we can place that here.
Let me see if that,
yeah.
Worked.
Let's see what happened.
All right,
so here's an example.
So what I did was it created an html table.
And in that I embedded,
let's look back at the code I embedded just these three little stripe scripts,
scripts I just copied and pasted from the stripe documents,
which basically says,
here's your data key.
Choose an amount you want them to pay and then just paste this in and they're
going to take care of it using this.
See how it's pulling from their javascript file to allow for this.
So just this,
these three pay with card buttons.
And so that's it.
So we didn't have to code any of that.
We'll just type in an email,
you know,
you can use a test card,
it doesn't,
you know,
work and CV and then you can click pay and then that's going to make a charge
for you.
So that's our payment functionality integrated into our APP now.
Okay.
So we have our payment functionality and now what we want to add are,
um,
what's next?
So we have our payment functionality.
We want to add the upload functionality,
right?
So,
uh,
we'll do this with html.
There we go.
Does he upload code?
Great.
Yeah,
thank you.
Html.
And we'll place it here.
If the user is authenticated only then,
then we'll let them upload,
right?
So there's that,
So now for the last bit,
we want to make sure that we are able to inference,
right?
So that's the whole point.
Once they've uploaded something,
we want them to be able to inference with that code.
And so the way we can do that is we're going to go into the routing file and so
okay,
so we're going to add a new route.
It's going to be called APP dot route.
Once somebody has uploaded
an image,
the uh,
you know,
it could be either get or post is going to be post.
These are our different curl commands to talk a little bit of a crud,
create,
read,
update,
delete to go back to like old school web development.
Now we'll upload a file,
right?
So once a user is uploaded a file,
we want to do something with that file.
And so we're going to import care os for this.
So we have to import care os and then we're going to say,
well if it's going to be a request,
if the request method is post,
get that file
and
get that model.
The resonant model,
the weights are there,
the weights are from image net,
which already exists.
This is pre pre training
or the are actually are retrained model,
which are,
which is a,
okay,
oh wait,
stop at age five,
the weight side h five file that we've pretrained and then we're gonna say,
okay.
So our image is going to be image dot load image and it's going to come directly
from
okay
the file
and that's our image.
Now we're going to use our model to make a prediction model dot predict with the
image.
And we will
return
you uploaded html page and we're going to return the predictions that it's made.
And then the,
uh,
on the uploaded an html page,
we'll take that data and we'll format it.
So it's in a pretty,
uh,
format for the doctors to be able to see predictions to coated.
Great.
Awesome.
So there we go.
So we have our inference code and then it's going to render it for the client.
Then what we can do is we can say,
let's pay by card,
you know,
so for the,
through the basic plan,
we're just going to say that it requires only,
you know,
10 bucks for a single image.
Now they can move on to higher plans,
but that's the basic plan.
And then once they paid,
then they'll choose a file and the file is going to be his file of a medical
image will help load it.
It's running in France like we coded out and then
once it's done it will display the result beautifully for us.
Boom,
98% pneumonia.
Okay,
so once we've done that,
we can move on to the next step and the next step is going to be to deploy it.
And the way we do that,
like the way I would do this is to just go to Heroku.
And so here's like a bunch of deployments that I added,
but it's really simple.
We just say,
okay,
in the director who say Heroku,
which is a keyword command,
say Heroku.
And so which is the one we want right here.
So right here we say Heroku create,
we'll create a remote Heroku,
create a remote branch.
Great.
We're in,
we created,
it's called stormy ridge.
Here's the link.
And now we say get in it,
get ad dot.
Get status.
That's everything.
Get commit.
M let me make this bigger.
You'd commit m yo get push Heroku,
push Heroku master.
All right,
so that's it for her Roku deployment.
And obviously now it's a,
it's an actual link.
We can link that to our domain.
We could switch it up with our landing page and there's a lot more we can do,
right?
So that was his 10th step.
Now in the future,
well can we do,
while we can obviously add a mobile app so doctors can classify with their,
uh,
mobile devices with their,
with their cameras,
and we can have it happen on the device with like low,
low power inferencing techniques,
core ml for ios and android has its whole whole suite as a whole suite dedicated
to this.
And then we can also make a better model,
right?
So one thing we can do is we can add batch inference so they can upload many,
many images all at once,
not just one.
Uh,
we can design it better.
Obviously the design could have been much better.
And also we can create a continuous serving pipeline.
And the best tool I've seen to do this is tensorflow serving.
I mean this is really,
really powerful stuff.
The whole idea behind serving,
which is the tensorflow library,
is that it builds this continuous pipeline of models that are training on new
data retraining.
And it's got this a version system where older models will be deprecated and
newer models will come in in real time.
So it's this continuous training pipeline where it's improving over time.
It's learning from its users,
data from your users data.
And this is very,
very powerful.
And it's,
it's,
it's what we want to do.
We want to make our system better with every image that it sees.
We want it to continuously improve and we want it to be robust and to always say
online.
So obviously I did not cover every single thing we needed to build an AI
startup,
but hopefully I gave you some education,
some inspiration.
Um,
and to just an example to show you that this is indeed possible and it is
something that you can do no matter who you are,
where you are,
this is something that you can do.
All right,
so and you'll find the code for this in the video description.
Hey,
I hope you liked this video.
Let me know when you thought of it in the comments section.
Hit the like button if you liked it,
and please subscribe for more programming videos for now.
I've got to take a break,
so thanks a lot.